[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti
vi ringrazio di questo invito e cercherò
di parlare di questo tema avanzare
retrocedendo classici e poesia fra
passato e futuro avanzare retrocedendo
discende dalla battuta di carlo emilio
gadda in un suo racconto degli
accoppiamenti giudiziosi che mestiere
difficile quello del consigliere dire e
non dire tastare senza toccare insinuare
senza ferire avanzare retrocedendo
questa fulminante battuta mi è sempre
sembrata adatta anche a dire qualcosa
del mestiere dell'antichità l'antichità
e naturalmente un deposito inesauribile
di bellezze di pensiero ed arte e la si
può raggiungere in varie in maniere a me
sta a cuore in questo contesto
segnalarne una speciale quella che passa
attraverso quelli che mi piace chiamare
i libri da conversione sono convinto
cioè che esista nella vita di ciascuno
ha postato da qualche parte un libro non
necessariamente un capolavoro della
letteratura o della scienza della
saggistica ma un libro adatto
specificamente a te che cambierà il
corso della tua esistenza così può per
esempio avvenire che un poeta tardo
latino come rutilio namaziano
sconosciuto ai più incontrato per caso
studiando per la maturità da uno
studente svogliato possa tradurre questo
studente svogliato in un saggista in un
letterato addirittura in un latinista e
questo forse addirittura in un
personaggio antico come è avvenuto
sottoscritto e questo solamente in virtù
dell'amore che si porta per un'avventura
umana che ci viene parlare nel caso di
rutilio si tratta di un viaggio da dio
alla città che ha amato da cui si deve
sradicare perché l'italia è stata
attraversata dall'ondata dei visigoti
deve tornare in patria restaurare i
propri possedimenti parte d'inverno con
poche barche costeggiando a piccole
tappe in italia
a cielo e ne tiene un diario poetico
questa storia affascina lo studente e lo
trasforma appunto in qualche maniera in
routine e ammazzano e in un latinista
queste conversioni riposano naturalmente
su qualcosa di ancora più misterioso che
ciò che ciascuno di noi si porta dentro
ovverosia ciò che chiamiamo una
vocazione nel caso di un letterato
questa vocazione può essere contigua
alla poesia la ricerca relativa
all'espressione poetica e ancora più
spesso forse della domanda perché ti
occupi dei classici a cosa servono i
classici ci si sente formulare la
domanda ma che cos'è la poesia a cosa
serve la poesia in questi casi quando mi
viene chiesto
faccio riferimento tanto per cominciare
a una foto molto famosa questa foto
scattata nel porto di corta delle isole
azzorre il 15 febbraio del 1986 mentre
infuriava una grande tempesta di mare
con onde alte più di 60 metri
il fotografo fosse enrique azevedo solo
due anni più tardi riguardando questi
scatti e questo in particolare si rese
conto di che cosa fosse successo se non
l'avete già visto guardate bene questa
foto perché fra due secondi lo vedrete
in tutt'altra maniera e non sarete più
capaci di tornare indietro
infatti se si segue l'onda che si frange
sullo scoglio sinistra piano piano si
intravede un profilo che sembra un
profilo umano quasi che il fotografo
avesse catturato la presenza del mitico
dio del mare in questo scatenarsi della
tempesta in porta
ecco naturalmente è un'immagine mentale
è un caso fortunato per questo fotografo
però finisce che questa immagine mentale
e la celebrità della foto lo sta a
dimostrare diventa più importante
dell'immagine
perché acquisisce un livello maggiore di
spessore di penetrazione di significati
simbolici
a me piace pensare che la poesia
funzioni così a uno sguardo sulla realtà
che ti consente a prescindere dal caso
di un nettuno inesistente di vedere ciò
che esiste è anche ciò che noi pensiamo
che esista stratificato su quella che è
la feriale percezione che abbiamo delle
cose in più ci si aggiunge anche un
livello formale che utilizza in un
dettato in forte scarto rispetto al
linguaggio banale della quotidianità ciò
che viene percepito e quindi restituisce
anche plausibilità perfino a temi molto
logo di che per loro natura sarebbero
forse anche classificabili come temi
lisi a me la poesia è venuta incontro e
quindi mi sento di raccomandare ogni
stile di vita che si incentra sulla
poesia che faccia nella poesia qualcosa
di fondamentale e mi è venuta incontro
in documenti banali un verbale di un
condominio un testamento medievale
alcune lapidi incontrate in un cimitero
perfino in una arrogante circolare di un
mio passato preside di facoltà
ciascuno di questi documenti dava uno
spaccato sul mondo parlava una sua
lingua introduceva un universo e
introduceva una percezione approfondita
di quell'universo incontro con la poesia
e conversione nei riguardi
dell'antichità hanno fatto sì che il mio
avanzare retrocedendo se sia configurato
soprattutto come tentativo di tradurre
testi di poeti antichi in poesia
italiana contemporanea
naturalmente questa modalità del
avanzare retrocedendo è soggetta a una
serie di speculazioni che hanno
depositato molti studi e non abbiamo
certo tempo di occuparcene
a me interessa solo sottolineare che il
mio personale tentativo e quello molto
momento di servire il testo
restituendone tutti i valori possibili
quelli della costanza delle parole
quelle della figurazione dell'ornato e
anche soprattutto quelli del ritmo nel
caso dei poeti antichi è un discorso
molto delicato perché come sapete la
ritmicità del verso antico riposo su
criteri che ormai noi non siamo più in
grado di fruire ovverosia
sull'alternanza secondo determinate
configurazioni di sillabe brevi e
sillabe lunghe il nostro orecchio non è
più quantitativo e quindi non siamo in
grado di ricostruire
allora abbiamo attivato una lettura
convenzionale su cui non entro in
particolare che però ho voluto seguire
con m italiani nella traduzione per lo
meno dei due grandi virgilio e catullo e
pertanto mi permetto di offrirne
semplicemente uno specimen per far
capire qual è questa direzione in cui ho
cercato un modo di muovermi questi sono
alcuni famosi esametri di virgilio enea
che se ne vado a [ __ ] col padre sulle
spalle il figlio per mano ex fatus dato
assume rosso subiaco e col veste super
fulvi queen sterno pelle leonis succede
connery decs 3 se parvovirus detto
questo le spalle capaci e il collo
reclino copro di un drappo la pelle di
un fulvo leone mi addosso di anchise il
peso il piccolo judo si stringe alla
destra
e se quel padre coi passi nei quali e
questi sono invece degli endecasillabi
fa le cd catullo i famosissimi carni dei
baci d'inizio del carnet 5 vivamus mea
lesbia memus rumore sco e se non severi
o room omnes news e stime mousse assis
sole soci le reti di report nobiscum se
melo cedit brevis lux knox est per
petunia dormendo su viviamo noi 2000 è
sbiancato ai mugugni dei vecchi troppo
arcini tutti insieme
noi stimiamo di uno spicciolo solo i
soli si spengono e ritornano mano è
spenta che sia da breve luce notte
eterna e continua a dormire ma questo è
il primo privilegio di un traduttore di
testi antichi quello di poter parlare
attraverso la voce degli antichi o per
meglio dire poter far passare la voce di
un grande poeta attraverso il proprio
modesto tentativo poi chi avanza
retrocedendo studiando gli antichi a un
secondo privilegio quello di riuscire a
colmare nei casi in cui ci riesca una
distanza fra loro e noi e da questo
punto di vista per me l'attività della
traduzione va a convergere con una linea
di ricerca particolare che è quella di
cercare di dimostrare come l'impronta
degli antichi si è impressa
profondamente nel legato artistico e
letterario specifico di oggi così può
avvenire per esempio che un fenomeno
come quello dell'immigrazione venga
eletto con occhiali virgiliani da un
poeta milanese come tiziano rossi detto
immigrato sopra questo ovest strano
catrame bagnato impiantito fumando
sigaretta guardingo si trapianta ignoto
enea che mica lo si canta o ancora che
primo levi lega la sua esperienza di
internato ad auschwitz che passa prima
per l'internamento a fosso di campo di
smistamento attraverso le parole stesse
di catullo che abbiamo prima ricordato
io so cosa vuol dire non tornare
attraverso il filo spinato ho visto il
sole scendere e morire ho sentito
lacerarsi la carne le parole del vecchio
poeta possono i soli cade tornare a noi
quando la breve luce spenta una notte
infinita ed a dormire molti sono i casi
così coinvolgenti e così
commoventi che potremmo incontrare per
esempio questo del poeta di origini
ebraiche ungherese miklos noti che è
stato prima internato in un lager e poi
trucidato dalle truppe filo naziste
ungheresi quando è stata riaperta la
fossa comune in cui era stato gettato il
suo corpo sul suo impermeabile in una
tasca è stato ritrovato questo taccuino
che vedete qui fotografato con la
raccomandazione in cinque lingue di
salvare la poesia che vi aveva scritto
in detenzione aveva fermato i momenti
della sua drammatica avventura
attraverso le delicate modulazioni delle
bucoliche virgiliane o ancora fernando
pessoa che crea in grande poeta
portoghese un intero eteronimo un intero
alter ego di quelli di cui si compiaceva
come poeta oraziano come poeta dedito a
meditare in chiave oraziana sulla
caducità della nostra vita passare del
tempo e il contrasto che un carpe diem e
le schermaglie amorose vi possono
portare quale avanzamento si può
conseguire oggi retrocedendo per queste
vie verso il dettato dei grandi classici
e in particolare verso la loro poesia ma
certamente in un inesauribile continuo
processo di acquisizione della bellezza
per come cresce su se stessa è però
lecito e forse anche doveroso continuare
a illudersi che possa procurarci anche
un incremento di civiltà
anche se un carlo emilio gadda di oggi
non leggerebbe nel suo giornale notizie
troppo consolanti avanzare retrocedendo
d'altra parte non è una sola battuta di
garda o uno schema assunto da me che mi
faccio oggi suo sostenitore apologeta ma
in fondo un segreto dell'intera
produzione artistica di tutti i tempi e
lo dimostro chiudendo spostandomi in
tutt'altro ambito cronologico e
geografico la cina del iii secolo con
questo poeta
soldato che si chiama luigi e che ha
scritto questi bei versi quando studio
le opere dei maestri
osservo l'operare della loro mente ogni
scrittore scopre una nuova via d'accesso
al mistero ed è cosa difficile da
spiegare il poeta sta al centro di un
universo contempla l'enigma e trae
nutrimento dai capolavori del passato
imparare a recitare i classici cantare
nella chiara virtù degli antichi maestri
esplorare i tesori dei classici dove
nascono forma e contenuto così mosso
accanto nei miei libri prendo in mano il
pennello per passare a comporre il mio
problema io vi ringrazio
[Applauso]